comme un duo qui m'a quand même beaucoup
plus profondément marqué et c'est à jo
que quand même de 15 joueurs
[Musique]
moi j'ai la chance les plus grands
artistes français après il ya des gens
dans la chanson française que j'aime
beaucoup comme francesca vrai sur vrai
qu' on peut le faire hein c'est vrai je
suis apte à 110 ans non mes chevaux
chauffer francis cabrel mois francis
cabrel et aimerait faire un duo avec lui
m'a dit non lui dire francis francis ça
va être le même rythme tu vois genre je
ne suis pas un lover lover lover dans la
calade
[Musique]
bon
jours
tu es fan de 8 ans jégou moi je connais
tous elle est surprise devant puisque
jusqu'à redescendre mais les connais pas
pas que je connaissais fiche connaît les
chansons qu'elle avait de fait dans des
mixtapes même je vous annonce ce soir
que vous êtes disque d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
embolique le dise que le relais avec un
petit souci est que le disque d'or c'est
je crois que certains ont pété le dise
non
la production alors
[Applaudissements]
j'apprends solide seaman toi
on n'a pas le portillon n'a pas l'autre
partie bah voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
cinquante mille albums pour du c'est un
carton bravo les chéris grave et on peut
l'appeler
[Applaudissements]